let's talk about jobs we are starting to
see better and better jobs numbers
as coronavirus cases have been declining
hospitalizations have been declining
deaths while still tragically high
are also declining and hopefully this is
going to continue
in february non-farm payrolls went
up 379 000 even though the expectation
was only 210
000 so the real numbers exceeding the
expectations
by about 50 percent in more in fact
the unemployment rate was expected to be
6.3 percent it came in
lower at 6.2 percent and this is of
course
just the start there is a huge way to go
to recover from this pandemic the
pandemic is nowhere near over
2 000 people a day are still dying
every day in the united states although
we're starting to to point
to below those numbers but this is still
something now
let's do the normal disclaimers on the
show if you're a new viewer or a new
listener
i don't play these republican democrat
games with jobs numbers
and with the unemployment rate that i
know that on a lot of shows they do this
with gas prices
they do this with debt and deficit they
do this with unemployment numbers and
jobs numbers this is not the show if
you're looking for that garbage
first of all this has very little to do
with joe biden
so far joe biden is rolling out vaccines
much faster than donald trump was that's
good
and that is starting to help cases go
down
that is the effect of helping businesses
to open but that moves really really
slowly
this is not really about joe biden right
now
this is a result of broader economic
circumstances
the pandemic and it has little to do
with biden
nor trump although for sure had we had a
real adult response to the pandemic from
the federal government
starting a year ago when it was trump we
never would have lost as many jobs as we
lost and of course we never would have
lost as many people
as we tragically lost but we've talked
about this many times before
uh and when we talk about jobs numbers
and administrations
second lots of people play this game
of oh david you're talking about the u3
when it's convenient
but you should really be talking about
the u6
i hate to even have to do this again but
as a reminder
there are many unemployment rates when
you hear on the news
the unemployment rate they are almost
always talking about what's called the
u3
there is another unemployment rate
called the u6 the u6
includes the people that we talk about
when we say
6.2 percent are unemployed but you add
to that discouraged workers in other
words those who
have not found a job want one but are
discouraged they're not even looking
anymore
and you add in people who are working
part-time but would rather be working
full-time they're only part-time because
they can't find a full-time job and
people love to play games
when the u3 goes down but you want to
criticize the president you say well
let's look at the u6
which is always higher right now over
the last month the u6 is
unchanged it's at 11.1 there's no reason
to hide that
again this is not really a story about
joe biden anyway
this is a story about the reality of the
pandemic i know lots of shows love to
mess with this stuff we don't do that
the hospitality industry is still three
and a half million jobs
short of where it was a year ago before
the pandemic exploded and if you look at
total employment
we have a long way to go there were more
than 152 million jobs before the
pandemic
there are now 143 million we are nine
million jobs
short of the pre-pandemic numbers uh
despite having more people living in the
united states than we did a year ago
now another attack on these numbers
that's meant to hurt joe biden
is people saying well but david a lot of
these new jobs are part-time
jobs that's true and there are some
unique circumstances right now that
explain that lots of businesses are
slowly reopening businesses that have
been closed
or places that have been reduced for
example to
a restaurant that's take out only um
that is going to start going in the
direction of
opening back up a lot of these
businesses are bringing people
back in for just a few days per week
and hopefully if all goes well if we
continue to do the things we have to do
many of those part-time jobs will turn
to full-time jobs as things continue to
recover
this is 90 percent about the reality of
the situation not about trump or biden
per se with the very important caveat
that if trump had managed this well
it never would have gotten as bad as it
got so the takeaway
is slow improvements the better
vaccination rollout goes
and the more people resist the urge to
just
open everything wide open and go crazy
the more quickly these numbers are going
to be able to recover
if things go perfectly i mean listen
there's different estimates if things go
perfectly
you could see the bulk of the recovery
happen during this calendar year
some industries are even if everything
goes as well as possible
will not be fully recovered this year
regardless and
travel some estimates say travel won't
fully recover
until summer of 2022 or even later
i think you know things change so
quickly that any predictions going so
far out are of limited value but the
point is we still have
a long road ahead of us and it's made
longer
by people like the ones i'm going to
talk about next
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 percent off when you use the coupon
code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical